[Music]  it was a truly happy Easter for Kylie  Jenner who celebrated for the first time  as a mom  Kylie's pal iris Palmer posted this  sweet moment to snapchat Kylie cuddled  up with boyfriend Travis Scott and their  two month old daughter stormy  Travis spoiled his baby girl with lots  of sweet kisses I love it after keeping  her pregnancy a secret Kylie revealed on  February 4th she had given birth to a  healthy baby girl ever since she shared  many adorable snaps on social media et  was with glam ma Kris Jenner just days  after baby stormy made her big debut  what is it like seeing your baby be a  mama it's so good yeah that was good  yeah it does it's it's incredible I feel  very very lucky and blessed life is  really good right now and it's all about  the kids and the family and just keeping  everybody happy and healthy  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]